[Music]
on this Thursday night the RCMP s offer
to the wit so it the Mounties offer to
meet a key demand I do not believe it as
new blockades pop up and what so it and
hereditary Chiefs meet with Mohawks from
one quarantine to another I just want to
be in Canada the next wave of Canadians
flying back and what happens to the
Diamond Princess cruise ship now
addicted and imprisoned the system is
set up to send me back one man's battle
to break a vicious cycle plus the radio
producer and the prisoner my first
reaction to that was like oh my god this
guy's a monster a Canadian man
surprising connection with a Guantanamo
Bay detainee
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
after weeks of illegal blockades of
railway lines in support of a group of
what so it in the hereditary Chiefs
there's still no resolution in sight
there is an offer on the table though to
meet one of their demands the RCMP have
offered to leave their outpost on a road
in which so itand territory
the one where arrests took place earlier
this month as long as that road remains
clear the federal government hopes it
clears the way for a peaceful resolution
everyone wants to take the air out of
this balloon in the most controlled way
the problem is most people are coming up
with us with a pin and that isn't the
right solution right now there is no
solution just growing anger the block
this blockade is on the main line
between Quebec City Montreal and the
u.s. it's blocking via passenger trains
and seeing freight trains cn did get an
injunction today to dismantle it and
Quebec Premier says police will act on
it this is ridiculous it's not the same
as blocking and in Canada so tacky or on
the First Nations land you're blocking
the major artery to get into our city
and in BC a blockade has been set up
east of Kamloops on land belonging to
the nest Connell if banned it's
affecting CP rail lines the RCMP are on
the scene there the other development
today involves a group of wood so itand
hereditary chiefs who have traveled from
northern BC to southern Ontario
they're the ones who object to the
natural gas pipeline going through their
territory a sharp contrast to the other
chiefs and elected band councils who
support it we'll get to all of that in
just a moment but first Eric Sorensen on
what if any progress was made today
two weeks after arrests in BC triggered
indigenous standoffs across the country
the RCMP have offered to leave their
outpost on the wetzel territory and
pulled back to their detachment in
Houston BC if the entire service Road
area stays open a breakthrough they've
listened to the concerns that were
raised by the hereditary chiefs and by
the community and I think they've
responded in a very appropriate way for
the government it would be a welcome
opening as a way to end the block
aids that have paralyzed rail
transportation in parts of the country
these are opportunities to come to a
peaceful resolution which is what we've
always aimed for from the beginning
the RCMP pullout is a core demand of the
wetsuit and hereditary Chiefs one band
member part of an earlier formal RCMP
complaint reacted to the potential
pullback with skepticism I do not
believe it and I won't believe it until
literally they have moved out in with
certain territory we've had a pretty
long history of poor treatment by the
RCMP what remains unclear is the level
of support among the wet sort and for
the protests versus those for the
coastal gas link project some don't
support the blockade the blockades
across Canada are not helping they are
further dividing our country they're
further dividing indigenous peoples and
non-indigenous people's the federal
Conservatives have taken a hard line
they believe the protesters are now
being rewarded
so what concessions is this government
contemplating to the lawbreakers and how
much more law breaking does this
government plan to encourage the Trudeau
government's tone is very different we
understand on this side of the house
that reconciliation remains a priority
not just for our government but for all
Canadians a separate question is the
precedent it would set if the RCMP the
frontline police force steps back what
would it mean for the pipeline project
and under what conditions with the RCMP
step back in Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto every day the blockades remain
in place the more the frustration builds
and now the woods oat and hereditary
chiefs at the heart of this impasse have
gone south to join the blockade on the
Tyendinaga Mohawk territory in Ontario
is causing mass disruptions to Canadian
rail traffic Global's Michael Couture is
in Thai and Onaga today Mike what do we
know about what they would sow it in
hereditary Chiefs are doing there well
Donna we're hearing that the Witte sword
in hereditary Chiefs are spending two
days with the Mohawks here and then
they'll be spending two days in Ghana
[ __ ] a to spend time with members of that
community in
goal of this trip is to thank them for
their support in solidarity but also to
chart a path forward the report suggests
Friday we'll start with a tobacco
burning at sunrise at the Mohawk council
house here on the territory and then at
10 a.m. will be a meeting with the local
council to discuss what are being called
political issues media and police are
being told to stay away from that
session while all other Mohawks are
welcome as for here in kinda Nega the
people camped out at the rails seem
ready to stay for as long as it takes
and we tried to speak with the
demonstrators to get a sense of how they
are feeling and you can tell that
tensions are running high as we're told
in no uncertain terms that they didn't
want to talk to us and we were to return
where the rest of the media have been
observing for weeks now it's a sharp
contrast to even a few days ago when
they were more open that's perhaps an
indication where we are in this standoff
as all sides are hoping for a resolution
and are frustrated that one hasn't come
yet now we did see people coming and
going over the course of the day and
many of them bringing food and coffee to
the demonstrators just like these two
twin sisters from a neighboring town
they've never blocked the track it's
just a digitus people trying to get
other people to understand that they
have rights that have been been trampled
on for centuries though the sisters who
have been coming here on nearly a daily
basis tell us that the Mohawks are in
good spirits but like everyone they hope
that this comes to a peaceful resolution
as soon as possible
Donna Mike look at Turrentine de Nega
territory in Ontario thanks there has
been a deadly development involving that
cruise ship in Japan infected with the
new coronavirus authorities say two
elderly passengers have now died and
their deaths
marked another grim turn in what's been
a disastrous few weeks on the diamond
princess despite being under quarantine
more than 630 people have contracted the
virus about 200 Canadians who were on
the ship are now on a flight back to
Canada as Mike Armstrong reports dozens
of other Canadians who tested positive
for Kovac 19 have been left behind only
supposed to be in on
occasionally it's been a surreal two
weeks for area Trudell his parents have
been stuck on the diamond princess
posting pictures on facebook these were
taken Thursday as the couple was moved
off the ship to a hospital
his father's tested positive for kovat
19 hood as says he wishes sick Canadians
were included in the repatriation flight
but they'd be better off being treated
here yeah in quarantine in Canada yes
we're sure 100% several countries are
now bringing back their citizens this
was an Australian couple leaving a
diamond princess the Canadian flight is
headed to Trenton Ontario with about 200
people on board Global News spoke to a
New Brunswick couple on the bus headed
to the airport they're facing 14 more
days in quarantine in Cornwall Ontario
but they're not complaining as the ship
empties out questions are still swirling
about how the virus spread what started
with a handful of cases turned into more
than 16 percent of the ship infected a
Japanese infectious diseases expert who
criticized protocols has now pulled his
video Cantara
Iwata told reporters Thursday it served
its purpose but he wada has been
criticized in the Japanese legislature
the government says it's done its best
and has been correcting problems daily
the president of Princess Cruises
visited passengers leaving the ship now
when it's empty it will be out of
commission the plan is to move the
diamond princess to drydock and give it
what's being called a full sanitizing
they expect it back in the water by the
beginning of May once again with
passengers Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal in China authorities are
reporting a drop in new cases of kovin
19 they say just over 400 new cases were
confirmed on Friday the drop appears to
be partly due to more changes in the way
patients are diagnosed in nearby South
Korea authorities are in crisis mode as
the virus begins to spread there 31 new
cases were confirmed in South Korea
today bringing the total to 104 and one
person has died a vast majority of the
new cases there are late
fringe religious group in the city of
daegu the group which has been accused
of being a cult says it's temporarily
shut its doors to help stop the spread
the city's mayor though is taking no
chances he's called the outbreak an
unprecedented crisis and he's urging
everyone in the city of two and a half
million people to stay indoors Roger
stone the longtime political strategist
and friend of President Trump has been
sentenced to 40 months in prison much
less than the seven to nine years
prosecutors had originally asked for
stone was convicted of lying to protect
Trump and Trump then said he thought
stone should be exonerated as Jackson
prosecco reports the question now is
whether President Trump will step in
again to try to save his friend he lied
and intimidated witnesses to protect the
president for that political bad boy
Roger stone will spend 40 months in jail
less time than recommended after the US
Attorney General overruled prosecutors
and after the president complained about
the sentence stone originally faced nine
years for doing something that nobody
even can define what he did Judge Amy
Berman Jackson said that her decision
was not motivated by politics saying
stone was not prosecuted for standing up
for the president he was prosecuted for
covering up for the president Roger has
a very good chance of exoneration in my
opinion Trump responded by attacking the
jurors who found stone guilty suggesting
the case will be overturned on appeal
I want the process to play out I think
that's the best thing to do the worst
kept secret in Washington is that Roger
stone will all but certainly receive a
full presidential pardon Donald Trump
has made it clear in recent days that he
plans to stand by his longtime political
adviser a man convicted of trying to
stymie the investigation into Russian
election interference it's already been
a good week for friends of Trump with a
slew of Pardons and commutations I want
to kiss my wife and my daughters the
former governor of Illinois and the
former New York City police commissioner
among them
a pardon for stone would carry a
different kind of weight he's the sixth
presidential associate convicted in the
wake of the Muller probe but his case
has become a lightning rod for Trump's
grievances with the investigation into
his campaign Jackson Prost go Global
News Washington as the Democrats
whittled down who will be their
candidate to go up against Donald Trump
they're holding a series of debates last
night was the first appearance for
billionaire businessman and former New
York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg he
took a beating from his Democratic
rivals who questioned his extreme wealth
and his record on how he treated women
and racial minorities likes to talk
about who were running against a
billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg Elizabeth Warren
went on to accused Bloomberg of muzzling
his accusers with non-disclosure
agreements the billionaire had been
rising in the polls after mounting a
multi-million dollar advertising
campaign Germany is in mourning tonight
coming up the shooting rampages being
treated as far-right terrorism plus you
can thank this man every time you've cut
and paste
three teenagers face a number of charges
after a violent armed bank robbery in
Markham Ontario
it happened at a Royal Bank branch last
night police alleged the boys aged 13 15
and 16 were armed with guns and knives
two bank employees were stabbed two
other people were kicked in the face
injuries that are all
non-life-threatening investigators say
they have evidence connecting the three
teenage boys to other unsolved robberies
throughout the Greater Toronto Area
Germany has suffered one of its worst
mass shootings Wednesday night a man
suspected of links to far-right
extremist groups attacked two shisha
bars killing at least nine people the
attacks which have been labeled acts of
domestic terror happened about 10:00
p.m. in a town 25 kilometres from
Frankfurt Germany Angela Merkel says
there are many signs the attacker acted
out of racism
police say the 43 year old suspect
killed himself at home he was found dead
next to the body of his mother
prosecutors say the man posted a
manifesto on the Internet
with a deeply racist attitude days
before the attacks well you probably use
what he invented almost every day but
you don't know it now it's your chance
to pay tribute to Larry Tesler who has
died at the age of 74 tesslar was a
pioneer of early computer and believed
computers should be for everyone his
most famous invention is the cut copy
and paste command which he came up with
while working at Xerox it was based on
the old method of editing in which
people physically cut portions of the
text and glued them elsewhere
tesslar was recruited by Steve Jobs at
Apple and rose to be that company's
chief scientist Xerox said today your
workday is easier thanks to his
revolutionary ideas still ahead when
mental illness and the legal system
intersect an intimate look through the
lens of one man's struggle
the number of people who are
incarcerated and struggle with serious
mental health and addiction issues is on
the rise for many interacting with the
legal system can be a vicious cycle
dealing with relapses and moving in and
out of prison one man caught up in that
cycle has shared his story with global
news we've been following Elliott
Hudson's case for a year and a half
here's Abigail Beeman with part one of
our series addicted and imprisoned
Elliott Hudson gets the macaroni and
cheese started for dinner people are
gonna see me and they're gonna say that
guy looks pretty normal I can relate to
you know what he looks like he looks
like somebody I could have went to high
school with that's part of why he's
opening up to break the stigma around
addictions and mental illness anyone can
be affected for more than two decades
since his teens he's been struggling
drugs alcoholism bipolar disorder and
anxiety two assault charges there was
assault police in total Hudson says he
has nine convictions one night you know
the that the mental torture was was so
bad that I thought you know either I'm
gonna jump off the the bridge into the
Ottawa River or or I can just try and
get as high and drunk as possible to
blot it out in 2017 he went from being a
master's student to homeless so
desperate for money to feed his
addiction he robbed two places landing
him in jail for the first time
yeah it feels like a long time from
where I'm sitting
Global News first met Hudson in jail
once he got out it took just a few days
before he broke his parole conditions
getting drunk and then coming clean
about it with his parole officer was
enough to land him back behind bars
once I had you know disclosed that I had
drank she had no choice that the system
is set up to send me back and the
criminalization of addiction is
something Hudson says needs to change
he feels fortunate to have served about
half of his nearly two years behind bars
in this Brockville Ontario treatment
center but with only a hundred beds he
got more help than many others so I've
been out today's my fifth day in October
Hudson was released trying to rebuild a
life nervous about relapse I'm really
grateful to have a comfortable space to
sleep like I said when I when I crawled
into bed at night I think about the guys
that are sleeping in shelters I woke up
clean and sober this morning I have no
intentions of using today and and
hopefully I go to bed the same way and
and then I and then I rinse and repeat
Hudson was able to stay sober for about
a month but when Global News met with
him last week I've been drinking
sporadically it's not it's not
continuous at this point but it's enough
to be concerning I can't be the person I
was meant to be when I'm drinking and
using he knows recovery doesn't happen
overnight and he knows his story isn't
unique
Hudson hopes sharing it may give others
like him a voice one that so often goes
unheard Abigail Beaman global news
Ottawa those who work with people like
Eliot Hudson say one of the biggest
challenges people I can face is stigma
about their addiction and lack of
understanding about treatment tomorrow
Abigail Beeman looks at how things need
to change that's in part two of our
series addicted and imprisoned next the
unique connection between a Toronto
radio producer and an alleged al-qaeda
explosives expert
imagine discovering someone who shares
exactly the same name as you that's kind
of freaky itself but this next story
takes that coincidence many steps
further a Canadian radio producer not
only discovered his namesake he traced
his story all the way to Guantanamo Bay
the detention facility set up by the US
during the war on terror and as Jeff's
simple reports had turned into a
fascinating three-year journey lot if
Nasser isn't a name you hear every day
in fact for a long time this radio
producer from Toronto thought he was the
only one until three years ago this was
the first time I'd ever found someone of
my name and he happens to be in the most
notorious prison on earth this was the
tweet that just launched me on this
entire investigation Nasser was idly
scrolling through Twitter when he came
across this tweet mentioning his name in
a letter to the President of the United
States and I was like what this doesn't
make any sense I read the letter and I
soon discovered it wasn't about me it
was about a guy who had my name who
happened to be a detainee two for four
at Guantanamo Bay the tweet was from a
human rights group calling for the
release of Abdul Latif Nasser locked up
at Guantanamo Bay detention camp since
2002 according to this leaked US
government document Nasser was accused
of being a top military adviser to Osama
bin Laden my first reaction to that was
like oh my god this guy's a monster and
just had this morbid curiosity I needed
to know everything about him I possibly
could
Nasser spent the next three years
investigating his namesakes story
interviewing the man's lawyer traveling
to Guantanamo and Morocco to meet his
family and the more he learned the more
that monster moniker didn't seem to fit
the more I dug into this guy's life I
found that we started in similar places
he was a nerdy Muslim kid from the
suburbs his lawyer says he's endured
years of torture despite never being
charged with a crime in fact in 2016 US
authorities actually approved Nasser's
release but that was before the election
of President Donald
Trump he's really stuck in in limbo
nobody in the current administration is
going to be willing to sign off on
transferring him entirely for political
reasons this is the other lot if I'm
what if Nasser Nasser is now releasing a
podcast detailing the other lot of story
based on dozens of interviews with
friends family military and intelligence
officials but the one person he couldn't
speak with was the man himself it almost
feels like the only place this guy has
ever gotten a trial is it's in my garage
we're going through this in this
meticulous way that I don't think
anybody else ever has before and and and
that isn't the way this is supposed to
work
just simple global news and that is
global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen
tonight's here Canada is the view from
mount Seymour in North Vancouver BC we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to us and thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow but I
[Music]